Packers quarterback Aaron Rodgers chimed
in yesterday with a post on Instagram
from the formation that we saw from many
different teams in 2017 as franchises
tried to decide how best to handle the
anthem controversy the locked arms and
Aaron Rodgers points out we were
criticized for locking arms in
solidarity before the game it has never
been about an anthem or a flag not then
not now listen with an open heart let's
educate ourselves and then turn word and
thought into action well set by Aaron
Rodgers and appropriate because the
issue has never been and never should
have been it got co-opted and turned
into something that it wasn't it was
never about respecting the flag it was
never about respecting the military it
was always about using the platform to
bring the attention the American people
especially those who aren't affected by
police brutality to this problem and to
commence the process of solving it and
if we only listen I you know it sounds
overly idealistic and I don't know maybe
it is but if we had truly listened if
the catalyst had been Colin Kaepernick's
message four years ago if that had been
the catalyst for the moment we're at now
it would have been better by now and
George Florida would be alive and others
would be alive if we had taken it
seriously when Kaepernick was trying to
get our attention instead of what so
many of us did plug ears and say you're
disrespecting the flag the military in
the country Chris so kudos Darren Rogers
and more need to say it never was about
the flag it's not about the flag stop it
if you're tempted to say it's about
disrespect stop it
it never was it never was it never will
be no and that's exactly right and well
you know hey Mike I mean this is why you
know this is why I love Aaron Rodgers
you know because he never stands on the
fence and tries to like play both sides
he's been out in front of this fight
from day one and again you know I think
you mentioned the last segment and that
it gets fair I think that's where Drew
Brees got in trouble he's trying to kind
of have them both ways there and it's
just not gonna fly this especially not
gonna fly and then I fell awkward right
down so yeah I always applauded Aaron
Rodgers
he is going to let you know where he
stands on a subject whether it's popular
or not he's smart he's well-thought-out
he he is very cultured in a lot of ways
and I thought that was a very good
statement there and you know it really
was Rogers is a great leader and I think
a lot of people in the NFL just from
what I even saw on TV last night
appreciate Aaron Rodgers and what he
continues to do and say you know about
this fight and there is risk in taking
that stand because their aim percentage
of the fan base that got upset at the
players in 2016 not look that they're
not nearly as loud now as they were then
and I'd like to think that some of those
folks who were so strident in their
refusal to accept the message of Colin
Kaepernick have maybe had an awakening
have may have maybe come to their senses
see and and that's why regardless of
your intent any any effort to bring back
the phrases that were used to ignore
Colin Kaepernick's message becomes a
potential lifeline for the people who
may be wavering the people thinking was
I wrong began des when you write when
you hear when you hear a drew brees or
anyone else in a position of prominence
repeat that you can grab it and you can
pull yourself out of these choppy waters
where you're not sure in your own
beliefs where you're uncomfortable in
the conversation and you and you find
refuge in don't disrespect the flag
don't disrespect the military don't
disrespect the country instead of
allowing yourself to stay out of your
comfort zone and wrestle internally with
these issues and ask yourself have I
been blind to what's going on in this
country do these do these ideals that
we're supposed to live by blind me to
the injustice that is around me every
single day that's what the folks who
didn't want to hear what Colin
Kaepernick had to say four years ago
need to be asking themselves have I been
blind and what will it now take for me
to see
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports